lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
probar
quiero probar
el segmento de línea hace es
perpendicular al segmento de línea de b
es decir que este segmento hace es
perpendicular a este segmento
dv como tip les diré que usaremos uno
más de nuestros postulados de
congruencia voy a escribir en esta parte
los postulados de nuestra caja de
herramientas lado lado lado lado
ángulo lado
ángulo lado ángulo y finalmente ángulo
ángulo lado todos estos son postulados
que implican congruencia aquí voy a usar
lo que se llama prueba de dos columnas
que es algo que normalmente se ve en las
clases introductorias de geometría y es
una idea muy básica en la que se expresa
un enunciado y se tienen que poner las
razones que apoyan a ese enunciado que
es lo que hemos venido haciendo con
nuestras pruebas pero que no hemos
expresado de manera muy estructurada voy
a escribir aquí
2 voy a usar aquí
dos columnas
dos columnas que se ven bonitas en la
primera columna voy a escribir el
enunciado
enunciado y en la otra columna voy a
poner la razón o razones que apoyan a
dicho enunciado
la estrategia que trataré de usar aquí
es primero probar que el triángulo a de
c es congruente con el triángulo a veces
basados en lado lado nada lo cual es un
buen punto de partida ya que una vez que
establezco congruencias puedo hablar de
ángulos iguales esto lo puedo afirmar
porque el segmento de ce está
establecido del diagrama es igual al
segmento veces
y el segmento ade también es igual al
segmento a b y ambos comparten el
segmento a hacer este de acá pero en
esta ocasión no quiero sólo mencionarlo
verbalmente sino escribirlo en mis
columnas así que lo escribo aquí en mi
segmento cd o mi lado cd es igual a mi
lado se ve esto está dado aquí en la
imagen
entonces en este segmento de c a d es
igual que el segmento de c a b
y también sabemos que el segmento
d
es igual al segmento
y lo escribo en mí
columna
el lado a d es igual al lado a b y de
esto también está dado
en este diagrama y también sabemos que
el lado ce
es igual al lado o sea que significa
esto bueno este segmento o sea es igual
a sí mismo es algo obvio está dado en el
diagrama dado y además es algo obvio que
este lado es compartido por ambos
triángulos así que tenemos dos
triángulos cuyos lados correspondientes
son los mismos y por lo tanto son
congruentes yo escribo que mi triángulo
de a
a este triángulo es congruente
congruente con mi triángulo
ah
y la razón es lado lado lado y de hecho
esto se apoya por los enunciados
anteriores que aquí yo creo que voy a
tener que enumerar para poder hacer
referencia más fácil este es mi primer
enunciado segundo enunciado tercer
enunciado cuarto enunciado así que se
apoya este lado lado al lado por los
enunciados 1 2 y 3
si estos triángulos son congruentes
entonces sabemos que todos los ángulos
correspondientes también lo serán es
decir este ángulo de acá va a ser igual
al ángulo que está aquí que su
correspondiente así que sabemos que esto
es nuestro quinto enunciado que la
medida del ángulo de ce
de c
es igual a la medida del ángulo de ce
este ángulo de c y esto viene
directamente del enunciado 4 esto viene
del enunciado 4 que es congruencia
con prudencia
ahora parece que podemos hacer algo
interesante con estos triángulos
pequeños de aquí de esta figura que
parece una cometa
estos triángulos comparten un lado y
tienen un lado congruente y también un
ángulo congruente entre ellos nuestro
sexto enunciado sexto enunciado es que
el segmento c
este de acá que comparten ambos
triángulos pues es igual es igual al
segmento c
esto también es algo obvio del diagrama
esto es obvio
del diagrama lo podemos ver
aquí hemos probado que tenemos un lado
congruente un ángulo congruente y otro
lado congruente entonces con lado ángulo
lado podemos afirmar que estos dos
triángulos son congruentes entre sí y
podemos decir que nuestro séptimo
enunciado es que el triángulo formado
por
es congruente con el triángulo formado
por d
y cuando escribo estas etiquetas de los
triángulos si en el primero lo inicié
con b con este punto el otro triángulo
lo voy a iniciar con be que es su
correspondiente el vértice que
corresponde a ambos el c lo escribo a la
mitad en ambos triángulos y ambos
terminan en él por lo que esos
triángulos terminan con el vértice en su
definición aquí como lo escribo y esto
es para especificar que corresponde con
que estos sabemos que es verdad por
nuestro postulado de lado de ángulo lado
que está apoyado a su vez por los
enunciados 1 5 y 6
5 y 6
y si ambos triángulos son congruentes
entonces sus respectivos ángulos lo
serán por ejemplo el ángulo que se
encuentra aquí de ese este ángulo de acá
es congruente con el ángulo formado
entre b y c este ángulo de acá
nuestro octavo enunciado dice que la
medida del ángulo d
es igual a la medida del ángulo b&c y
esto está apoyado por el enunciado 7 que
nos habla de congruencia
congruencia
también sabemos que nuestro noveno
anunciado
el ángulo de ese y el ángulo de
son suplementarios estos dos son
suplementarios quiere decir que la suma
de ambos ángulos nos da 180 grados como
vemos estos son 180 grados la suma de
estos ángulos no nos completa una media
vuelta a un medio círculo esto lo
sabemos al observar el diagrama así que
estos son adyacentes adyacentes son
ángulos adyacentes y los lados externos
y lados
externos de estos ángulos externos
forman ángulos ya no
forman un ángulo
forman ángulo
ángulo llano
ángulo ya no es el de 180 grados
nuestro décimo enunciado dice que la
medida del ángulo de s más la medida del
ángulo de s es igual a 180 grados esto
viene de este enunciado 9º que está aquí
atrás el onceavo enunciado nuestro
anunciado número 11 dice que la medida
del ángulo d
s más la medida del ángulo d
sé de sí mismo va a ser igual a 180
grados y esto viene de los enunciados 9
y 8 de que la medida de estos dos
ángulos a 180 grados y de que estos dos
ángulos son suplementarios nuestro
doceavo enunciado s nos dice que la
medida del ángulo d
es igual a 90 grados que a su vez eso es
igual a la medida del ángulo b
y esto viene de los renunciados 11 y 8
como pueden ver estoy trabajando muy a
detalle en esta demostración para no
obviar cosas y ya terminamos vamos a
escribir el último enunciado que es lo
que queremos probar nuestro último
enunciado el enunciado número 13 nos
dice que el segmento de línea a c
es perpendicular al segmento de línea de
b
es perpendicular a db y esto viene del
enunciado anterior del número 12 en el
que estos ángulos de ese y bs son igual
a 90 grados
con esto ya realizamos nuestra prueba de
dos columnas usando los postulados lado
a lado lado y lado ángulo lado